hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation or maybe
it's going to be or every other day
daily equation your semi daily equation
whatever it is your by daily equation I
never know what the right usage of those
words actually is but in any event I'm
going to focus today on the question the
issue the subject of black holes black
holes and black holes are an amazingly
rich arena for theorists to try out
ideas to explore our understanding of
the force of gravity to explore its
interaction with quantum mechanics and
as I will mention black holes are now
also an arena which is rich in fertile
for observational astronomy we've gone
beyond the era in which black holes were
merely theoretical ideas - now the
recognition that black holes are real
they are really out there I'll also know
at the end that there are great many
puzzles to do with black holes that have
yet to be resolved and maybe a 5-time I
mentioned a few of those but I'd like
for the most part to focus here in this
episode on the traditional more
straightforward widely well not
completely but more widely accepted
historical version of the trajectory
that led us to recognize the possibility
of black holes and some of the
properties that emerge from the basic
mathematics of Einstein's equations okay
so to get us going let me just give a
little bit of historical background the
story of black holes begins with this
fella right here Karl Schwarzschild he
was a German meteorologist mathematician
really smart guy astronomer who was
actually stationed on the Russian front
during World War one and as he's there
and he's charged with actually
calculating trajectories of bombs you
hear them going off and so on and
somehow in the
inches he gets hold of Einstein's paper
and the general theory of relativity
does some calculations on it and
realizes that if you have a spherical
mass and you crush it to a very small
size the bombs are still going up all
around him it will create such a warp in
the fabric of space that anything that
gets too close will not be able to pull
away and that's really what we mean by a
black hole it is a region of space in
which enough matter has been crushed to
a sufficiently small size that the
warpage is so significant that anything
that gets too close closer then as we
will see what is known as the event
horizon of the black hole cannot escape
cannot run away so sort of image that
you can have in mind is if we have a
little animation here of the moon going
around the Earth this is a usual story
of warped environment around the
vicinity of a spherical body like the
earth but if you crush the earth down to
a sufficiently small size the idea is
that the indentation would be far
greater than what we saw for the earth
the indentation would be so significant
that at least metaphorically speaking if
you're hanging out near the edge of a
black hole and you were to turn on a
flashlight if you were within the event
horizon the light from that flashlight
would not go off into deep space instead
it would go into the black hole itself
this image is a little bit off I should
say but it kind of gives you at least a
mental toehold for the idea of why it is
that light can't get away from a black
hole when you turn on a flashlight if
you're within the event horizon of a
black hole the light shines inward not
outward now another way of thinking
about this idea look I know this is
quite familiar territory
black holes are in the culture you know
the phrase falling into a black hole or
he did something and it created a black
hole we use that kind of language all
the time so all these ideas are familiar
but it's good to have mental imagery to
go along with the words and the mental
imagery that I'm about to give you I
find particularly interesting and useful
because there's a mathematical version
of the story that I'm going to show you
visually right
I'm not going to describe that
mathematically right now but just know
that there is a version of the so called
waterfall analogy that really can be
fully articulated in the mathematical
way that makes it rigorous so here's the
idea if you are near a waterfall and you
are say paddling your kayak paddling
your kayak if you can paddle faster than
the rate at which the water is flowing
toward the waterfall you can get away
but if you can't paddle faster than the
water is flowing then you can't get away
and you're doomed to fall down the
waterfall and here's the idea the
analogy is space itself falls over the
edge of a black hole
sort of like a waterfall of space and
the speed at which space travels over
the edge of a black hole is equal to the
speed of light nothing can go faster
than the speed of light so near a black
hole your doom so you might as well just
paddle right toward the black hole and
go on a joy ride down the throat of the
black hole itself so that's another way
of thinking about it edge of a black
hole event horizon space in some sense
is flowing over the edge it's flowing
over the edge at a speed equal to the
speed of light since nothing can go
faster than the speed of light you can't
paddle upstream and if you can't paddle
upstream you can't get away from the
black hole you're doomed
and you will fall in to the black hole
now that all is highly schematic and
metaphorical of hope it is useful for
thinking about black holes but for a
long time we knew what black hole should
look like if we were to ever see them we
wouldn't literally see the black hole
itself but in the environment around a
black hole as material is falling over
the event horizon of a black hole it
heats up the material rubs against the
other material that's all falling inward
it gets so hot that the frictional
forces heat up the material and they
generate x-rays those x-rays go out into
space
those x-rays are things that we can see
so let me now to show you therefore the
expected view of a black hole would be
something like this around the edge of
the black hole you see the swirling
maelstrom of material giving off these
high-energy x-rays I've put them in the
visible so we can see them and within
that maelstrom of activity is a central
region from which no light itself is
being released no light is being emitted
and that would be the black hole itself
now Schwarzschild you know was doing his
work as I said it was World War one so
we're back in 1917 or so and so he puts
forward this idea of this solution I'll
show you the mathematical form of that
solution as we go forward but there's a
real curious feature of other many
curious features of the solution but one
in particular is for an object to become
a black hole you got to squeeze it down
but how far do you have to squeeze it
down well the calculations show that
you'd have to squeeze the Sun down to
about three kilometers across or so to
be a black hole the earth you'd have to
squeeze it down to a radius of about
centimeter or so to be a black hole
everything about the earth down to a
centimeter it doesn't seem like there'd
be any physical process that would ever
allow material to be compressed to that
degree so the question is are these
objects just mathematical implications
of the general theory of relativity or
are they real and a step in the
direction of showing that the real was
taken some decades later when scientists
realized that there is a process that
could actually lead to matter collapsing
in on itself and thereby crushing it
down to the small sizes required for the
black hole solution to be realized
physically what are those processes well
here is the canonical one imagine we are
looking at a large star like a red giant
that star supports its own hefty mass
through nuclear processes in the core
but those nuclear processes which give
off the heat the light the pressure
ultimately they will use up the nuclear
fuel and when the fuel is used up the
star will now begin to implode
in on itself getting hotter and denser
toward the core until ultimately it will
heat up to such a degree that an
explosion will take place that explosion
will ripple through layer upon layer of
the star until the explosion ripples
right to the surface blows off the
surface of the star a supernova
explosion and what remains is a core
that doesn't have any nuclear reaction
to support it so that core will collapse
all the way down into a black hole a
black hole in space taking the form that
I showed you a moment ago a region from
which no light is escaping and this
image here you see the black hole's
gravity is bending the starlight around
it creating this interesting lensing
effect but that's at least a process in
principle that could lead to the
formation of a black hole now what about
actual observational data that supports
these ideas all this is highly
theoretical at the moment and look
there's been data accumulated for a long
time observations of the center of our
Milky Way galaxy showed that stars were
whipping around the center it says
fantastically high velocities and the
entity responsible for creating the
gravitational pull that was whipping in
them around was so incredibly tiny that
for a tiny region to give rise to the
gravity necessary to explain the
whipping motion of the orbiting stars
scientists concluded that the only thing
capable of doing that would be a black
hole so that was interesting in direct
evidence for the existence of black
holes perhaps the the most convincing
from a few years ago was the detection
of gravitational waves so you may recall
that if you have two orbiting objects
I'll do this at some point some episode
as they orbit they rippled the fabric of
space and as they ripple the fabric of
space they send out these wave train of
distortions in the space-time fabric
that in principle we can detect in fact
we did detect it first time back in 2015
and when the scientists did the analysis
as to what was responsible for the
squeezing and the stretching knot of
this degree as we see in this animation
of planet Earth but a fraction of atomic
diameter the arms of the LIGO detective
stretched and contracted in schematic
manner shown by this earth that's being
distorted when they worked out the
source of the gravitational waves the
answer came out to be two black holes
that were orbiting each other rapidly
and collided so that was nice
evidence in support of black holes but
of course the most convincing evidence
of all is to see a black hole and indeed
that's what in some sense the event
horizon telescope did so a consortium of
radio telescopes around the world were
able to focus on the center of a distant
galaxy m87 I believe and they combined
data that they were able to amass from
those observations gave rise to this
famous photograph photographing quotes
it's not actually a camera it's radio
telescopes but this famous photograph
where you see the tell-tale ingredients
you see the glowing gas around a dark
region black hole Wow amazing right
imagine that chain of events Einstein
writes down the general theory of
relativity 1915 it's published in 1916
some months later Schwarzschild gets a
hold of the manuscript works out the
solution to the equations for a
spherical body
he beats Einstein to the punch I
probably
to emphasize that early on Einstein
wrote down Einstein's equations of
course but he was not the first person
to solve those equations to solve them
exactly
Einstein wrote down approximate
solutions that are really good in
situations that are not too extreme like
the bending of starlight near the Sun
the motion of mercury its orbit these
are situations in which the gravity is
not strong so an approximate solution to
his equations is all they actually need
to work out the trajectory of starlight
or the trajectory of mercury but
Schwarzschild writes down the first
exact solution to Einstein's equations
of the general theory of relativity
wonderful achievement and embedded in
those in that solution to those
equations is the possibility of black
holes and then in whatever it is 2017
what was 2018 when was the event horizon
tell avoid time goes so fast whenever it
was 2018 19 and somewhere in there so
roughly speaking 100 cannot roughly
speaking a hundred years later we
actually have the closest you could
imagine to a photograph of a black ghost
so that's a that's a beautiful that's a
beautiful scientific story beautiful
scientific achievement what I want to do
now in the remaining time is just
quickly show you some of the math behind
all of this so let me actually switch
over to my iPad here why is it not
coming up oh please don't mess me up
here oh okay yes I think we're good let
me just write and see if it's coming up
yes good all right so we are talking
about black holes and let me just write
down some of the essential equations and
then I want to at least show you in the
math how you can get to some of the
iconic features of black holes that you
may know a lot about or at least you may
have heard over if you haven't they're
kind of mind-boggling in their own right
so what's the starting point the
starting point as always in this subject
is on
signs equations for gravity in the
general theory of relativity so you've
seen these before but let me write it
down our minou minus 1/2 g mu nu r
equals 8 pi Newton's constant g speed of
light fourth time's the energy momentum
tensor T mu nu so this first guy over
here this is a so-called Ricci tensor
scalar curvature energy momentum tensor
metric on space time and again remember
we are describing curvature in terms of
a distortion to the distance
relationships between points in a space
a good example if I can just switch back
over half a second here I showed you
this earlier but here's the Mona Lisa
painted on a flat canvas but if we
curved the canvas if we warp it if we
distort it look what happens the
distance relationships between points on
her face for example are being changed
so curvature is reflected in this way of
thinking about things as a distortion in
those distance relationships the metric
well let me go back good the metric over
here is what allows us to measure
distance relationships it defines the
distance relationships on a geometrical
space and that's why it comes into the
story so what we want to do now is to
take these equations and try to solve
them in a certain circumstance what's
that circumstance imagine you have some
central mass M imagine that say at the
origin of the coordinate system and
imagine that it's spherical and
everything else is spherically symmetric
and that gives us a simplification on
the metric because a general metric will
have distance relationships that can
vary in a non symmetric manner but if
we're looking at a physical circumstance
in which we have a spherically symmetric
mass then the metric will inherit that
symmetry it will be spherically
symmetric and that allows us to simplify
the analysis because the metric now has
a particularly special form so our goal
then is to
the following outside of this mass let
me just use a different color here and
say any of the regions of command please
any of these regions out here alright
outside of the mass itself there is no
energy momentum at all
so that would be T mu nu equals zero and
the only place in which the mass is
going to come into the story is when
they solve the differential equations
the boundary conditions at infinity will
need to reflect the fact that the space
does have a body within it but the
equations that we are going to solve are
the equations that are relevant external
to that body and outside of that body
there is no additional mass or energy
we're not going to imagine if any
swirling gas or any of the things that I
showed you in the animation would keep
it real simple so we're gonna solve the
Einstein field equations in a CEREC
sorry static spherically symmetric
circumstance in which the energy
momentum tensor outside of the central
mass is equal to zero it vanishes okay
so now let's do that now I'm not going
to actually take you through the
detailed analysis of finding the
solution not particularly illuminating
and I think you'd find it a little bit
boring for me to write down all the
terms but what I will do is I just want
to give you a feel for how complicated
the Einstein field equations in general
are so now what I'm going to do is very
quickly just write down those equations
in a more specific form okay so here we
go
so I'm going to write down here the
Riemann tensor quite quickly Riemann
tensor in terms of the Christoffel
connection that gives us parallel
transport I will then write down the
Ricci tensor and the scalar curvature
which has come from contracting the
Riemann tensor or longhairs indices are
then write down the connection in terms
of the metric and its derivatives and
this is the metric compatible connection
that ensures that under parallel
translation the lengths of vectors do
not change and therefore we have the
chain of events that we start with a
metric that gives us
the connection in terms of that metric
that gives us the curvature Riemann
curvature in terms of the connection in
terms of that metric and then we
contracted in the various ways as I've
shown you and that gives us the
left-hand side of mine Stein's equation
it's a complicated nonlinear
differential function of the metric so
we have a differential equation that we
need to solve and what happened is now
get to what Schwarzschild did he took
that complicated mess that I took just
rapidly showed you and he found an exact
solution to the equations let me write
down the solution that he found so as is
conventional I'll write down the metric
as G equals G alpha beta D X alpha D X
beta repeated indices are summed over I
don't always say that I don't always
write it but just recognize we're using
the Einstein summation convention so
alpha and beta are repeated which means
they run from 1 to 4 sometimes people
say 0 to 3 they're running over T XY and
Z whatever numbers you care to assign to
those particular variables so that is a
metric so what I need to write down now
is the particular coefficients G alpha
beta that Schwarz I was able to find in
solving those equations in the
circumstance that we were just looking
at and here is the solution that he
finds in the trenches when it should
have been calculating artillery
trajectories during World War one so he
finds that the metric G is equal to
let's write it in this form 1 minus 2 G
M over C squared R times well times C
squared I should write down here if I'm
gonna keep the season if it at least be
consistent C squared DT squared minus
well where should I write that already -
- 1 - 2 GM over C squared R to the minus
1 times D R squared plus the angular
part of the metric which I'll just write
down as R squared D Omega so I'm not
going to talk about the angular part at
all I'm just really interested in the
radial part and the temporal part the
angular part is symmetric so there's
nothing particularly interesting
happening there so there it is there is
the solution that Schwarzschild writes
down now when you look at the solution
there are a number of interesting things
let me just give myself a little bit of
space I wrote too big but I'll try to
squeeze it in over here so first of all
you might say to yourself the situation
of having a massive object M I'm gonna
do it there the situation of having a
massive object
well far away from that massive object
yeah it should sort of look like Newton
you would think alright and does it look
like Newton is there any hint of Isaac
Newton in the solution that
Schwarzschild found to these complicated
nonlinear partial differential equations
from Einsteins field equations and
indeed there is let me set C equal to 1
make it easier for us to recognize what
we're driving at just use the unit's
receipts equal to one one light year per
year whatever units you want to use and
then you will note that this term over
here has within it the combination GM
over R GM over R bring a bell right
that's the Newtonian gravitational
potential for a mass M say sitting at
the origin of the coordinates so you see
there is a remnant of Newton in that
equation in fact truth be told the way
you solve this equation is by making
contact with Newtonian gravity far away
from the R
so the solution itself builds it in from
the get-go as part of the way we find
the solution but be that as it may is
beautiful to see that you can extract
the Newtonian gravitational potential
from the Schwarzschild solution of the
Einstein field equations okay that's
point number one which is kind of nice
point number two that I want to make is
that there are some special values
special values of R well let me just
it's not like I'm lecturing in front of
a class but let me just write this now
so point number one we see Newtonian
gravitational potential in the solution
that's cool
point number two is that there are some
special values special values of R what
do I mean by that when we look at this
solution you notice in particular that
if R equals zero then some funny stuff
happens because you're guiding you
divided by zero in those coefficients of
the metric what does that mean well it
turns out that that's a big deal
that's the singularity the black hole
singularity you see right there the
Infinity that crops up as R goes to zero
in the coefficient of the metric but now
you might say well wait what about also
the value of R equals to GM or to GM
over C squared but C is equal to one of
these units that's a value for which
this term goes to zero and if it goes to
zero then this term is going to infinity
to another version of infinity cropping
up is that a singularity and people
thought that that was a singularity so R
equal to zero is right here but R equal
to what's known as RS the short style
value and let me call this RS to GM over
R people thought of course it's a whole
sphere that I'm going
drawing part of it early days people
thought that might be a singularity but
it turns out it's not actually a
singularity it's what's known as a
coordinate breakdown or some people say
coordinates singularity it's where the
coordinates don't work well you're
familiar with this from polar
coordinates right in polar coordinates
when using R and theta R theta well
that's a perfectly good way of talking
about a point such as that away from the
origin but if you're actually at the
origin and I say to you okay R is equal
to zero but what's Theta theta could be
point two point six pi pi if it doesn't
matter every angle at the origin is the
same point so the coordinates are not
good at that location similarly the
coordinates are T and then the angular
part theta and Phi are not good all
along R equals R s so so people have
understood this now for a while but R
equal to RS even though it's not a
singularity is a special location
because look at it when you are say
heading in from infinity and you get to
R equal to RS and then say you cross
over R equal to RS look what happens
here this term and this term they change
their signs right when R is bigger than
RS then this quantity over here is
smaller than one and therefore one - it
is a positive number but when R is
smaller than RS this term is now bigger
than one therefore one - it is negative
and therefore this picks up a non
negative sign as does this now the only
difference between a T and an R as far
as this metric is concerned is the sign
so if their signs flip then in some
sense space and time flip wow space and
time flip so as you go across the edge
what you thought was time become space
and what you thought was space becomes
time again because the only difference
between space and time as far as the
metric is concerned is this minus sign
over here oh and I wrote down things
funny here that was confusing this is
should be a minus sign also if I'm
putting the - in front of my space sorry
about that so go all the way back and
imagine that but the point is again
focusing just upon the radio and the
temporal part the only thing that
distinguishes the radio from the
temporal as far as the metric is
concerned is the sine a plus or a minus
and when you cross over or equal to RS
the plus and the minus interchange space
and time interchange and that actually
gives us one way of thinking about why
you can't escape from a black hole when
you cross over article 2 RS the spatial
direction is now better thought of as a
time direction and just as you are
unable to go back in time once you cross
over the event horizon you can't go back
in the r direction because the radial
direction is like a time direction so
just as you are in electively driven
forward in time second after second
after second once you cross over the
edge of a black hole you are in a luck
tably driven to smaller and smaller
values of r because it is if you are
being pulled forward in time so that's
another way of understanding this so in
particular the following is the black
hole summary that I want to give for a
physical body so I mentioned this before
if you're talking about the mass of the
Sun and you work out the Schwarzschild
rate it's just stick into this formula
to GM or to GM over C squared
you'll get that number that I mentioned
before I think it's I'm working from
memory here I think it's about 3
kilometers now that means that for a
body like the Sun let me make it nice
and orange for a body like the Sun
here's the Sun the Schwarzschild radius
is deeply embedded within the Sun and
you will recall that the solution that
we derived is only valid outside the
spherical body I set team you knew on
the right hand side of Einstein's
equation is equal to 0 so the solution
for
son say the Schwarzschild solution is
really only valid outside the Sun itself
which means that you will never get to
the Schwarzschild radius because it's
not part of the solution it's not that
you can't solve the Einstein equations
inside the body you can but the point is
everything that we're talking about is
only relevant outside the physical
boundary of the object itself and for a
body like the Sun or any typical star
the Schwarzschild radius is so small
that it's well within the object well
beyond the reach of the solution that we
are talking about similarly if you look
at the earth as I mentioned before you
plug that in short our radius 2gm earth
this is mass of Sun Earth over C squared
you get something on the order of
centimeters and again a centimeter is so
small compared to the size of the earth
that that source of radius is deeply
embedded within the core of the earth
but what is a black hole then a black
hole is an object whose physical size is
smaller than its own Schwarzschild
radius so if you take any mass at all
and you squeeze that mass down to a size
RS equals to GM over C squared just
calculate that if you can take that mass
and squeeze it down to a smaller than RS
eyes so squeeze it down so that R is
less than RS a lot of squeezing but
whatever imagine that it happens now the
Schwarzschild radius is outside the
physical boundary of the object itself
now the Schwarzschild radius really
matters it is part of the domain within
which the solution holds and therefore
you have the possibility of crossing
over the edge of the Schwarzschild
radius as we were talking about over
here and then space and time interchange
you can't get out all that good stuff
follows from there that's really what a
black hole is final point that I want to
make you may have heard this idea that
when you get closer and closer to a
massive body
I'm gonna stick with black holes just
because it's more traumatic but it's
really for any massive body at all
as you get closer and closer to the edge
of a black hole so imagine we have a
black hole again the singularity at the
center what does that mean it means we
don't know what's going on there the
metric blows up our understanding breaks
down no I'm not gonna try to explain
that any further here basically because
I don't have anything to say I don't
know what happens there but if this say
is the event horizon that I just drew
over there you may have heard that as
you head in from infinity and you get
closer and closer and closer to the
event horizon of the black hole you find
that time elapsed is slower and slower
and slower clocks tick ever slower
compared to the rate at which they ticks
a way out here at infinity so if you
have a clock out here and you bring in a
clock over here the idea is that it
ticks slower and slower let me actually
show you that I have a nice little
visual on that so here you have clocks
that are ticking next to each other far
away say from a body like the Sun bring
one clock closer and closer to the
surface of the Sun it actually is
ticking slower it's just the effect is
so small for a regular ordinary object
like a star like a Sun that the effect
is too small to see but now if you
squeeze the Sun down into a black hole
now you're allowed to bring the clock
closer and closer the Sun doesn't get in
the way the clock can get closer and
closer to the event horizon and look at
how that clock is ticking ever more
slowly good now going back over here can
we see that effect in the equations and
indeed you can my equations have become
so incredibly messy as I draw all these
little things that maybe I can clean up
oh that's pretty
in fact I can get rid of all all these
things and the fact I can change this
little guy over here from a plus to a
minus everybody's looking
real cool here alright what's my point
though my point is I want to focus my
attention here I go again on this term
over here let me just rewrite that term
without the mess around it so that first
term just looked like that's not what I
want to write the first term choose a
different color something that's good so
I had 1 - 2 G M over R putting the EC
equal to 1 times DT squared that's what
the metric looks like now this DT part
over here think about that as the time
interval right ticking of a clock delta
T is the time between the clock being in
one location and say a second later now
when R goes to infinity this term over
here goes to 0 so you can think about DT
or DT squared as measuring how clock
ticks far away infinitely far away from
a black hole where this coefficient goes
to 1 because the 2 GM over R goes to 0
at infinity but now as you go on your
journey toward the edge of a black hole
this is the journey we are going on this
R now is getting smaller and smaller
this quantity over here is getting
bigger and bigger still less than one
outside the Schwarzschild radius which
means that this combined guy is getting
smaller and smaller what does that mean
well what that means is we have a number
in front times DT squared this number is
getting small as R approaches the
Schwarzschild radius and it goes to 0
there that small number is multiplying
the time interval delta T squared or DT
squared and that's giving you the
physical time that it takes for a clock
to tick at a given radius and because
that number is getting smaller and
smaller time is ticking slower and
slower so there it is it's the fact that
this term over here
is getting smaller and smaller as you
get closer and closes approaching zero
as R goes to RS it's that coefficient
getting smaller and smaller that is
giving the slower and slower rate at
which clocks tick as they go on this
journey toward the edge of a black hole
so there it is that is the slowing of
time near the edge of any massive body
doesn't have to be a black hole black
hole again as we saw in the animation
just allows you to get closer and closer
to the Schwarzschild radius where that
coefficient gets closer and closer to
zero making the effect more and more
manifest all right look there are a lot
a lot of puzzles of black holes I've
just scratched the surface here we're
only talking about black holes that have
mass they don't have charge that's
another black hole solution you also can
have black holes with angular momentum
which in the real world they typically
will have those solutions have been
written down to exactly what happens at
the deep interior point of a black hole
the singularity there still things that
people struggle with in fact when you
put quantum mechanics into the story
this is just classical general
relativity no quantum mechanics when you
put quantum mechanics into the story
even what happens at the edge the event
horizon of a black hole is now open for
discussion oh sorry got something all
right here even that's open for
discussion and has been vigorously
discussed in recent years and there's
still questions that people argue about
even there but this gives you at least
the the classical story the basic
underpinnings of the history of how we
came to this possibility of black holes
the observational story which
establishes that this stuff is not just
in the mind but it's actually real and
then you see some of the mathematical
manipulations responsible for some of
the essential conclusions about how big
an object needs to be squeezed down to
four to be a black hole and the fact
that time itself elapsed is slower and
slower even that shaped the the usual
funnel shape you can see from the
mathematics as well
should probably stop but I'm getting
carried away as I often do look at this
term over here so much as this term
showed us that time is elapsing ever
slower toward the edge of a black hole
the fact that you've got this guy over
here with a minus one there means that
in some sense distances are being
stretched out as you get closer and
closer to the edge of a black hole how
do you stretch out those distances well
one way to graphically represent that is
you you take that that plane and you
stretch it out and you get that big
indentation that big indentation is
representing this term that we have over
here because it's getting ever bigger as
you get ever closer to the edge of a
black hole ever bigger means ever bigger
stretch anyway it's kind of fun to see
the pictures come to life through the
mathematics and that was really the
point that I wanted to get across here
today with this first exact solution of
the Einstein field equations come from
Karl Schwarzschild the Schwarzschild
solution which again works not just for
black holes for any spherically
symmetric spherically symmetric massive
body like the earth or the Sun for black
holes it's a particularly dramatic
solution as we can get right down to the
event horizon and probe gravity in
unusual domains that Newton would not
have been able to understand or reveal
to us based on his own equations of
course if Newton were around today he
would totally understand what's going on
he would be leading the charge okay
that's really all I wanted to talk about
here today I'll pick this up again
shortly not exactly sure if it'll be
every day as I've mentioned before but
until next time this has been your daily
equation take care